should at the descendants of Sally
Hemings be also buried in the family
without a doubt that graveyard is for
Jefferson descendants in there Jefferson
descendants you know you don't have to
be buried every but if you want to be
ought to have the right to I don't need
the graveyard you know I don't want to
be buried there I believe I should have
the right to be buried there are the
choice to be buried there if I did
choose to when this first started the
family was fifty-fifty I think there was
a lot of splits a lot of the Martha
Jefferson side of the family have come
around to accept the Hemings side of the
family and I've been loving and knowing
each other as family and cousins so
times have changed but I think when we
get to a point where we can fully live
out dr. King's dream and you know the
sons of former slaves and the sons of
former slave owners can't sit down at
the table of brotherhood and
reconciliation and be buried together
then chime has changed and hopefully
we'll get to that point in my lifetime
where we will be able to live together
and be buried together